[Music]
welcome
to the mit center for art science and
technology's 2021 symposium
unfolding intelligence the art and
science of contemporary computation
cast was established in 2012 with the
goal of building and building on
connections between the worlds of art
science and technology
this is the third in a series of
symposia the cast has convened since
then and
as with its predecessors we bring
together artists
scientists engineers and humanists from
within mit and from the world at large
to discuss areas of rapidly evolving
research and urgent
social relevance and defined in that
dialogue
stimulation confirmation provocation
intersection
and we hope common purpose
at mit cass partners with departments
labs and centers to integrate the arts
across the curriculum
to enrich and encourage artistic
collaboration and to provide support to
faculty and members of the mit community
as they pursue their own artistic
practice and or research
in addition to symposia like this cass
facilitates the sharing of this creative
work beyond the institute
by producing concerts exhibitions and
publications
and making them available to the public
so thank you for being with us today we
hope you will join us throughout the
week
at virtual events addressing the
aesthetic technical
and critical issues pertaining to
artificial intelligence
and computational media we also
look forward to seeing you on friday
april 9th as the symposium culminates
with a live interactive event to which
all attendees are invited
and which you can join presenters and
artists in breakout rooms
to explore hidden threads between all
that has been discussed
this week
welcome my name is caroline jones and
i'm an art historian teaching
in history theory criticism section
of the department of architecture here
at mit
this is my recorded introduction to the
first of two sessions on the theme
of open systems in the unfolding
intelligence symposium
hosted by the center for art science and
technology
this event is also supported by the
transmedia storytelling initiative
our recorded presentations will be
followed by a live discussion
and q a i want to thank mellon postdoc
will lock it and cast director leela
kenny
for making this symposium a reality
during the long tale of a pandemic
assisted by katherine higgins as the
open system session producer
we will be holding the second part of
our session this evening at 5 00 pm
eastern daylight time i do hope that
those listening might be able to come to
both
so that we can have the kind of
cumulative and collaborative
conversation
that we so miss from pre-pandemic times
please feel free to ask any questions
during this webcast
on the webpage you'll find links to the
entire symposium
our colleagues at the list visual arts
center are also hosting related events
on the future of ai that i hope you can
visit we joke about the fire hose of
information at mit
and this week of events is no exception
i want to begin my brief introduction by
speaking the words of mit's recently
achieved
land acknowledgement although we gather
virtually
the resources and capacities of the
institute come from being a land-grant
university
based on the ongoing occupation settling
and colonization
of existing people's land mit
acknowledges
indigenous peoples as the traditional
stewards
of this land recognizing the enduring
relationship that exists between them
and their traditional territories
the land on which we sit is the
traditional unseated territory
of the wampanoag nation among others we
acknowledge the painful history of
genocide and forced occupation of their
territory
and we honor and respect the many
diverse
indigenous peoples connected to this
land from time
immemorial acknowledging the living
indigenous communities here in
massachusetts is important to me
and this evening session will open
directly onto questions
of indigenous epistemologies of kinship
in machinic
and earth systems framed in biology as
mutualism
in our ecologies and algorithms in our
machine learning prostheses
but this morning's session is quite
different i have set our two
extraordinary speakers
a different charge since they both
operate out of
northern europe and deal with those
cultural imaginaries on a daily basis
first let me introduce them briefly and
then explain the
somewhat challenging charge that i gave
them for today's conversation
i first came to know laura's van larsen
through his very clever anthology
networks issued in 2014 but this
prolific curator critic has also issued
other edited volumes the 2014
phantoms of liberty fundamentalism
of the new order in 2018 and two
different versions
of the new model in 2020.
i sought out artist jenna in 2018
after seeing her extraordinary
performance extremophile
at the serpentine marathon in which the
clean suit
she wore served as the backdrop for the
projection of an amazing film
about our relations and sonic
meditations
um on our interplanetary relations with
extremophile bacteria
in 2019 i was thrilled to learn that
lars was organizing an exhibition
mud muses that would include jenna's
work
the mederna museum exhibition is named
for the composition
of bubbling mud that i'm showing you
here by
earlier art and technology artist robert
rashenberg
riffing on rauschenberg's expansive and
improvisatory aesthetic
lars encouraged us to think about
technology not as
a 20th century thing of electronics and
metal
or a 21st century thing of algorithms
but courtesy of ursula le guin's rant
about technology
mobilizing her expanded definition of
technology
as the active human interface with the
material world
in this case mining mud but in yena's
case
imaginary magma bubbling inside a series
of activated lava lamp glass heads
molded from her own countenance jenna
then used machine learning to read the
random shapes morphing in the heads
for several other compositions i'm sure
they'll be talking about
suta's work has been featured at art
museums and contexts internationally
including guggenheim bilbao
and larsa's show at modena musee and in
an upcoming exhibition
and edition of e-flux i'm happy that she
accepted our invitation to be a visiting
artist here at mit
despite covid and i'm sure she'll talk
about the work she's doing
with my physicist colleague marcus
buehler in her upcoming conversation
with lars
the a.i that yanasutala deploys can riff
on the chemical and kinetic activity of
molecules
on their larger aggregation in
primordial organisms
or on the fluid dynamics of psychedelic
wax
to get out of the way of their
discussion i'll cut to the chase
i knew that lars was the right
intellectual to draw jenna out
on the subject of an alternative
definition
of ai as alien intelligence
from the intelligence the poorly
understood gut brain
of the microbes that govern our human
moods to the intelligence of other than
human
entities in the universe for me open
systems implies opening out
intelligence to these different kinds of
forms that might be machinically more
than human
or organically multi-species or
cosmically
other the question that unites this
morning in this evening session
is how opening our machinic systems to
these questions of alien
or more than human cognition really
raises the stakes
of our fantasies of computers as
potentially sentient
entities if artificial intelligence so
closely modeled on humans
is seen as alien instead
we have to do a lot more work to figure
out how it operates
and how it culturally signifies i was
inspired by sutado's work with slime
molds
as models for distributed cognition and
by lars's encyclopedic knowledge of
popular culture tropes
to ask them to consider alien
intelligence
as prefigured in cold war science
fiction
which might have been particularly
intense and suited as native finland
on the border between the soviet union
and its nato counterparts
if illustrators of h.g wells imagined
his martians as spidery or octopoid
alien
zapping people through electric wires
and transformers coming out of their
bodies
the post-nuclear imaginary of aliens
became distinctly humanoid
these hairless big-eyed cranial
domed scarily sentient aliens
appeared during the atomic age fueled by
u.s nuclear
weapons testing in the nevada desert as
well as
mono amano with soviet underground
nuclear tests
in the mutually a third assured threat
of biocidal destruction
i thought lars was just the person to
excavate
the bizarre length that i can intuit
between eastern bloc
cybernetic theorists such as the urban
designer branco petrovic
whose effluent man of 1971
seems uncannily prescient of our ep
like tropes a greenish-white embryonic
creatures of unknown
intention since lars put petrovic
into one of his recent exhibitions he's
more qualified than most to talk with
jenna
about this weirder side of how we model
cybernetic
modes of future intelligence and in
soothless work this feedback looping can
embrace slime molds as well as
lava heads exhibiting more than human
cognitive facilities
months ago when i invited them to join
this symposium
i particularly challenged these
profoundly creative individuals
to explore the whiteness of ai
in the figure of the powerful cold war
alien
it's not easy to situate jenna's
gorgeous crystal heads with their color
sorted magma
into discourses of wraith particularly
when works such as extremophile
and hula biont are explicitly engaged
with swarm cognition
in bacteria that might have 700 sexes
and no capacity to be raced at all
at least not so far but to invoke the
alien
in us discourse is to engage the atomic
age fantasies
of a superior perhaps sinister possibly
beneficent
but in any case dominating humanoid
concepts of intelligence that track
with deeply biased algorithms in white
favoring tech
so while it's not required that lars and
jenna unpack this complex
for those of us here in the u.s i'd be
grateful if they could
in their brilliant conversation agree to
talk with me
about this matter after their recorded
presentations
are concluded an aid to our discussion
might be found in the recent work of
artist ryan quo
who trenchantly questions the way
whiteness functions on our screens
as a kind of default subject position
his computational works emerges apps
websites and occasionally videos shown
here
is a still from his work okay also
pertinent
is the fully complex meditation he calls
pointer to sum up this challenge to the
alienating effects of our ai
with a final bit of my own meditation on
computation's whiteness
i remind you that the pointer finger
originated in the animated glove pan
of mickey mouse from early american
cinema
itself a remnant of the live minstrel
show in which fight white performers
appropriated black song and dance
this in turn became the cute little
pixelated hand
of another kind of mouth only 50 years
later
the navigational computer mouse whose
clicks and drags are now harvested by ai
from our networked computers
yana sutala by moving to the radical
alternative bacterial movements
to train machine learning obviously
avoid the algorithmic bias built into
human speech recognition
and not to mention the racial bias built
into facial recognitions
incapacities and homophilies echo
chambers
creating software to construct martian
glossolalia
and a beautiful illegible script from
divinings of microbial
movement and machine learning sutella's
take on the whiteness of ai may well
intend to skip the cultural baggage of
human imaginaries altogether
seeking the absolute open system of a
planet
not our own let us turn the screen
over to lars and jenna for their
conversations
on open systems and i'll rejoin
after the end point so that we can take
questions
and have a discussion with you the
audience thank you
thank you caroline and thank you for the
invitation to
here at unfolding intelligence
i'll just say that for our conversation
and the sienna knows
i framed my questions to a work around
the simple genealogy
of western esoteric counter cultures
so my questions take the starting point
and elements of witchcraft spiritualism
and psychedelia that can be found
in guinness work and research
[Music]
now esoterica can be broadly defined
as embodied other knowledges and
knowledge of others
or as embodied other intelligences and
intelligence of others
and that's including more than human
others of course whether they're ghosts
or aliens or more abstract entities such
as
fields of energy and other imperceptible
agents and arenas of being
it's in this sense that haunting has
become an indispensable attitude to
history
cultural theorist carla fraccero writes
that quote to assume the perspective of
the ghosts
foregrounds the imperative issuing from
the other in the labor
of the historian unquote so a historical
space
that is haunted by a dramatic and
violent past can be opened up
until days that potentially refashion
social relations
and what we think we know
[Music]
um it must also be said that what i
broadly call
western esoterica also has proven to be
politically unstable
and ambiguous esoterica tends to
bring institutional chaos with it and
certain forms of it has
historically been employed to legitimize
oppressive regimes
so our conversation on open systems and
on vienna's work
revolves around what you could call
political ecologies
of historical knowledges that have that
were or are
inimical or marginal to the modern
constitution
from the others point of view and our
conversation will deal with the
techniques that have been employed by
counter cultural groups to produce
system errors
in the program of western modernity
often by memes of what gloria and
valdour has called spiritual activism
[Music]
witchcraft spiritualism and psychedelia
are counter traditions within empire
they are not situated outside of empire
but at its limits
and as such they can be tested against
the principle
of epistemic disobedience that walter
mignolet sees
as a prerequisite for decolonization
we'll start with witchcraft and there is
a web
of patriarchal domination that connects
the development of capitalism
colonialism and the repression of women
in her amazing book caliban and the
witch from 2004
silvia federici shows how primitive
accumulation took shape in the middle
ages
in the form of the capitalist orders
colonial expansion
for the purpose of building an entirely
new economy in the so-called new world
an expansion that was combined with the
subsumption of women
into the social reproduction the witch
hunts
in europe implied a continental famous
eyes
and with this the eradication of other
knowledges which women
as carers and knowers of communities
had been primary carriers
in this way patriarchy demonized
witchcraft as a gender transgression
into the realm of the more than human
magic remedies were means of such
transports
thus in 17th century denmark
witches farmer copaya included fecal
pancakes with which you could supposedly
transfer vitality
from a healthy person to the weak and
ill
and this act of consuming thesis was of
course considered an attack of
on the values of the lutheran church but
it can also be seen to represent an
entirely different organization of the
relation between the human and the more
than human
and jenna is from you that i have the
story of
danish fecal pancakes i know that
previously you have worked with god
machine poetry but
equal pancakes how do they factor into
your work
yeah so i've been really curious about
that particular piece of danish
history and the pancake remedy
which feels closely related to fecal
microbiota
transplants a form of bacterial
therapy that i've been studying as part
of my residency at
mit and yeah as the story goes there was
a case of witchcraft reported on the
island of
bornholm in 1679 where a pancake had
nearly poisoned the farmhand
and the court documents reveal that at
the core of this case was actually an
attempt to
cure a sickly child by transferring
crafter or
vitality from another healthy child born
at the same time
and the transfer was to happen through
pancakes made from the feces of the
healthy child
in the size of a hen's egg apparently
unfortunately the pancakes didn't work
to cure the child and they were
accidentally fed to a farmhand
who then reported it and during the
trial it was revealed that this practice
had been common
to the region in earlier times and i've
also
read about an even deeper history of
fecal transplants in 4th century china
for the treatment of food poisoning
anyway what i'm mostly interested in are
the possible
mental health benefits of such bacterial
therapies
the connection between the microbiome
and our thoughts and emotions
the ability of excrement to cure
depression
in particular and it certainly feels
like some kind of a
circle is closing when the most
prominent method
methods for treating depression seem to
be excrement and and ketamine
at the moment and another suggested
method is to breathe uh
mycobacterium vaccine from the soil
while
gardening anyway i'm fascinated by the
fact that
we're more bacteria than so-called human
cells
as as donna haraway put it to be a one
at all you must be a mini
in my work on the gut brain axis i'm
exploring this kind of
multiplicity as an alternative to
individuality
also the idea that through fecal
transplants or
pancakes we can accommodate the bacteria
of
others i really want to
celebrate our commingling with bacteria
and human bodies as
connected environments um i've
encountered some
fascinating projects at the at the
campus uh stool based biobanks and
that focus on collecting and preserving
the biodiversity of human gut microbes
for future generations astrobiologists
studying coprolites sewage epidemiology
and
and this sort of stuff um
right um we should go on to spiritualism
because in uh in spiritualism in 19th
century spiritualism there is a history
of
[Music]
automation
that that is hidden in there you could
say so spirit mediums especially young
women
were understood to be capable of
entering into contact with the spirits
of the dead
the medium was a channeler a receiver of
messages from the other side as it were
messages to be broadcast to the living
and in this way the
the medium was seen as a telesubject to
put it like that
someone with enhanced connectivity
this idea of the medium as a conduit
between worlds led to practices
of automatic writing in which
the conscious subject takes the backseat
and
supposedly allows for someone or
something
else another intelligence to to take
control
now as an unholy mix
of science and religion spiritualism had
an affirmative relation to new
technology
so for instance in 1854 there was a
group of
spiritualists who petitioned the u.s
congress for funding
to develop a so-called spirit telegraph
and that's a kind of super powerful
telegraph for communication with the
spirits of the dead
they didn't get the funding i can reveal
but there's congress for you isn't it
um but now you know your work
nimiya city i i guess it's pronounced
is based on the 19th century swiss
medium helen smith's
automatic rising and oral transmissions
which she herself referred to as
communication with
martians in martian language
so in a non-human alien language
for this project you collaborated
you could say with the wonderfully named
bacteria bacillus subtilis which is
found
in the human gut but it's also been
taken on space flight to mars
to test the limits of life so in your
work
anemia or anemia setting
an ai generated a script based on
observations of the activity of the
bacteria
and a neural network trained on your
voice produced sound to match the
configuration of bacteria
over time the machine learning process
developed a language of its own and
became capable of
writing and just to explain you
recorded with your own voice whatever
you could find of smith's writing
does interpreting or bastardizing
smith's
martian language with your own voice and
this was used to teach
the ai
yeah so my question
the media cci is why do we need
an entirely new language or for which
new community
do we need
in the in the words of uh madeleine
jeans and arakawa
we must forget language and all those
mechanisms that structure us
via the world and so stutter our way to
divinity
and a lot of my recent work has been
interfering with language or trying to
sense the world in
some other way um that's because i find
it difficult to truly collaborate with
life forms with which we don't share a
language and and
yet i'd like to do just that that
um my friend k allied mcdowell recently
wrote the book
uh pharmacoai together with openai's
neural net language model gbt3
they describe the writing process as
experimentation with
a language ecology that's not limited to
human meaning and i really relate to
this type of
linguistic project
thank you
[Music]
time is running i can i can tell we
should
we should jump to psychedelia which
another topic that's on the edge of the
symbolic order
[Music]
and this this concerns your new project
wet on wet which is a collaboration
through
mit center for art science and
technology here you work with
the material scientist marcus j buehler
who has developed a method for
expressing molecular vibrations in
audibles and of course vibrations or the
vibe
was an archetypal probe of 60s
counterculture as we know from the beach
boys song
about good vibrations but together with
beulah you've compiled
a sonic toolkit for amplifying the waves
of emotional
molecules in domestic waters
and this is inspired by masaru emoto's
idea about what
the blueprint priority and how different
emotional energies and vibrations can
change the physical
structure of
wet on wet sounds like hydro feminism
that meets speculative materialism in a
kind of
nano synesthesia
the theorist steve goodman has said that
human audition is a fold on the
vibratory
continuum of matter so human addiction
is not
isolated to one modality one kind of
perception but touches
other sensors and induces other material
responses
um to begin with could you just briefly
explain what
are these emotional molecules that you
work with
so marcus and i work with seven
molecules the
lavender bonding hormone oxytocin the
neurotransmitters dopamine serotonin and
norepinephrine
the energy carrying atp a growth factor
and an antibody
and yeah the first outcome of the
project will be
a video where one can hear and see
visualizations of
molecular vibrations that are resonating
in this kind of
waldorf style wet on wet painting that i
have been doing for block down
meditation
and the sonified molecules are imprinted
on the surface
of water using an acoustic transducer
additional patterns are generated by a
neural network that has learned from
the molecular ripples and and is now
seeing them
everywhere um yeah and you refer to the
the domestic orders and since the work
will initially be presented online and
experienced
at home i'm hoping to make it more
tangible or
felt by encouraging people to amplify
the presence of these
so-called emotional molecules in their
domestic environments
through programming the molecular
vibrations into water for yeah
painting drinking cooking bathing
fermenting farming
watering plants etc
one will be able to do this by taking a
thin glass vessel with a small amount of
water inside
and placing the vessel on their mobile
phone while it's playing the sound of a
molecule
in the video and the idea comes from
masaru emoto's experiments
which you also refer to among other
esoteric practices around water memory
or
dosing water with spiritual potentials
the topic of sonifying microscopic even
nanoscale phenomena is very interesting
to me um
observing life by listening instead of
only looking um marcus will actually
join me in a breakout session tomorrow
to talk more about
his method before i met marcus i had
also been in discussion with
physicist jim jamsevsky who's known for
his work on sonocytology at the ucla
and particularly for the screaming east
uh
that's um that anthropologist sofia roos
who i also met
here on the campus has written so well
about
um jim cevsky is basically using the tip
of a microscope like a needle on a
record
and and the record so far has consisted
of
yeast cells great
just to uh to get back to the political
ecologies i have a
long difficult question um
again my my starting point this is the
idea of of
of the vibration or yeah the good
vibration because in
60s counterculture the the vibe
was conceived as something more than
audible right it was
uh the virtuality of the tremble
that had to be picked up as it were
more than heard actually so so for those
who were tuned in
and experienced and in the know the vibe
was conducive to a special kind of
fluid subjectivity
that could open up to any becoming any
transformation supposedly
uh so in relation to what on west this
is something that you
that you link to you you conceptualize
through a discussion of
oceanic feelings as a sense of
oneness with the world or a
limitlessness
so on a neurochemical level you point
out and now i'm quoting you
this feeling quote is triggered by the
love and bonding hormone or citizen
the oceanic has the potential to
unsettle subjectivity
it can be a point of departure for new
social and political models that do not
rely on discrete selves
on quote so i'm wondering about the
oceanic
as a political concept already freud
was troubled by the identification of
religious feeling as
something limitless
what if you don't feel part of this
indissoluble
bond of being one with the external
world you wrote
and then and then in the 1960s
as a historian of architecture felicity
scott points out
counter-cultural claims to oceanic
feelings operated not as the welcoming
of strangers but
at the expense of politics so
if we follow freud and felicity got the
oceanic feeling rather undermines
political encounters
uh at least political encounters that
are premised on
self-conscious decisions this can be
contrasted with that part of
60's counter culture that wasn't
premised on oceanic universalism
namely the black power movement that
rejected the idea of universalism and
instead advanced the claim of
particularism today
theorists such as jane bennett and pono
latura
and others are perhaps more on the
oceanic side of things
for instance when jane bennett
emphasizes
distributed agency and what she calls
the pop public as the product of
conjoined action
[Music]
so my question is you know
why do you use the concept of the
oceanic
and how can we use this concept today
without
falling into the traps uh outlined by
freud
and missed by the hippies and and how
does the oceanic translate to
to current political concerns and
and concepts
so i've been focusing on inter-species
alliances and
and rethinking humanity in a material
and
worldly setting i was always inspired by
uh geologists diana and mark mcmenamin's
idea about the hyperc according to which
terrestrial organisms are bonded by
their commingling
body fluids and that together form
a sea through which other organisms and
nutrients can move
and similarly astrida naiminis writes
about the flow and flush of waters that
sustain our own bodies but also connect
them to other bodies and to other worlds
beyond
our human selves i i'd like to think of
the
oceanic as a common identity that can
help us act together
for them advancement of collective and
also beyond human
interest and of course we should work
towards distributing the future
evenly both socially and environmentally
speaking and
and finding university of unity in
diversity or the particularities that
you mentioned
um i remember this lecture by rossi
freitas in castel some years ago
um where she asked since when was human
and all-inclusive category and and
continued
that she'd rather run with the bacteria
right at the unpacked the kind of
over-inflated image of
human as the measure of all things
pointing out how even the concept of
post-human
fails to really stand for post-power
post-class post-gender post-race
and she called into question how that
which is
which is human depends on a process of
exclusion
and that we were not all human to begin
with
great thank you i think that's a
a great note on which to finish
and i guess our time is up now as well
i'll see you in the discussion
wow that was fantastic um
i wish we were in the same yeah i wish
we were breathing the same molecules but
we're having to transduce ourselves
through a comprehensive set of
algorithms
running lars over zoom vienna over the
web
interface i don't know where i am i want
to just hone in
on this beautiful place that you ended
us
with jenna and
you know could could ai
yeah could we possibly turn this
human-addled biased
set of algorithmic languages um
and machine learning protocols
into some sort of oceanic connector i
mean that this is the
this is the task in some sense of the
entire symposium
what are the promises of ai what are the
perils of ai
i chose to highlight your engagement
with the ai
as alien but it is this
incredibly powerful connector
for you in your work so maybe
maybe you could help us think about that
as your own very creative problem and
very creative process
how do you engage the machine learning
algorithms as both
alien and as both connecting you to
others
uh yes first of all i didn't manage to
give my
thanks in the recorded session so here
it goes
thank you caroline for the invitation
and
and thank you cast for having me as a
president artist and and happy to be
talking with you lars and caroline
today live um
yeah so um a lot of my recent work
explores these kinds of um
ghosts in the machines of our creation
um for example the the the so-called
black box problem in machine learning
means that it's sometimes hard to
explain how an ai has come
to its conclusions so
and on the one hand the work such as
nimiya seti or imagma
is about getting in touch with the
non-human condition of the computers
that work
as our interlocutors and infrastructure
but on the other hand it's also about
the computers
escaping their human origins and and
getting in touch with themselves
and the more than human world around
them
so so i've i've been exposing the the
machines to bacterial movements
um randomness in in a bubbling kombucha
tea culture
which consists of of this symbiotic
colony of bacteria and yeast
or most recently ripples based on
vibrations from the sounds of molecules
so i guess there's this sort of idea
about um could machines have
some sort of embodied cognition because
i've been
like caroline also mentioned or you
mentioned in the
introduction um i've been looking into
the microbiome or the the composition of
microorganisms living in our guts
and and their effects on our our
thoughts
and emotions so so i somehow
wanted to move some sort of thinking
from this territory to to the realm of
machines
as well um
and i'm not sure if i'm fully answering
it was a big question
also about connecting i think it's i
think there are many questions and we
can just
keep keep going with them i mean lars
brought so many beautiful writers to all
of these questions he can probably also
jump
in with some references for us but
um i love the black box problem
and when i wrote a question to start us
off i was actually thinking
of a computer scientist judah pearl
who tells us we should be frightened
because
the place that machine learning has gone
with so-called deep learning where it
where it teaches itself
is no longer comprehensible to computer
scientists
in other words they see the outcome
but they don't know as scientists how to
trust it
because they no longer understand the
steps the machine took
to get that answer right so for computer
science
the black box is a very serious
place of anxiety um and
it's also a place of science fiction the
singularity
you know the machine general
intelligence
is going to happen and so on what i love
about your responses
and and your processes is that they come
down
to these quite specific projects of
translation
where you're actually interested in the
alien operations
of the machine you know in in what what
patterns it will find
that are different from the ones ones
you can so i
i i mean i encourage lars to come in on
this idea of the black box
and particularly lars with the
provocation at the end
which is where you know how do black
boxes relate to black power
so you know the um the black community
is very actively rewriting algorithms
right and they're very dedicated to
uh putting human difference back
in something like a sentencing algorithm
which is supposedly determining
on the basis of past patterns whether
that human
should go to prison or not right so in
other words it's a very
active social area of programming
and yet for engineers the black box is
supposed to be
you know absolutely neutral and
objective
so by by by applying the ai to some sort
of
fluids you know you're insisting on ai
as a way of connecting
between difference anyway so i'm just
surfacing this
massive tangle hoping maybe lars can
start us off with untangling it
thank you caroline that was a big arc
you would think yeah but but uh i think
your question is part of
about you know how to connect uh
through something this also does
uh that's a problem of mediation
well that's that's where many of these
questions
last obviously to uh
to start and like you did yourself when
you introduced in the 20th century
i think the uh the the four of
the black box uh is is the
rough it's it's it's measure of the
mainframe
or is these uh uh it's not close to what
we eat
we are getting right now we are getting
a kind of a
total word salad a word
salad made out of the garden the
cybernetic garden you're trying to
conjure
for us um i wish we had you know i wish
you could
like type some of these uh apisu for us
because we're
we're literally kind of getting every
third word which is the machine's
decision
about what we should be able to hear
from you
but it's all good it's all good we're
starting to get some
some questions from um the audience and
i want to
bring those in too because those are
those are precious parts of our
community
so one question got named so i'm just
going to tell the audience that like
they get farther if they put their name
on it so matthew richie
who's also part of this symposium says
proposing a division between the oceanic
or immersive in the particular
seems to miss out on the concept of the
coastal community
bridging the space between the
particular and the commons through
highly localized technologies and
practical edge farming
practices so the the the question coming
out of that comment
is can we find an ethics on the
technologies
of edges i don't know where you want to
take that poetically but
that's that's the question
you know that's also a sculptor's a
sculptor's question
yeah so you know you've made you've made
different kinds of edges
for slime mold to navigate
and then there's of course a
disciplinary component because they're
the edges of disciplines
that we might try to dissolve in any
case that's matthew's
contribution to the conversation
and perhaps this somehow goes back to
the the particularities that that we
were talking about with
with lars as well if i if i understand
the
question right that it's
[Music]
about things not fully blending in but
also appreciating the
the edges or particularities
if i if i understand it it
writes so for example like um
i'm not sure if this is going into the
the right direction but but i was
i was thinking how um
um with this with this idea of the hyper
c
or being connected aquatic environments
uh
uh through our bodies um
and and and wanting to be kind of a
good good host to say the bacteria that
that live in us and move through us and
live in other bodies and
and so on but uh
we should also think about for example
the the
the network the the human and and
and more than human network that that
this
that we really need to host to and
and to consider the most uh efficient
ways to
to sort of uh
benefit different kinds of
particularities and and
uh and different
cultural bacterial and living conditions
um some of them uh compromised
um yeah so so i i just kind of read this
question i don't know if i'm really
going into a
totally other other field that may be
kind of similar to the
into species relations that i've been
dealing with the the survival of the
fitness narrative won't do
also in in even human relations or
or yeah so i think that you know the
oceania
i think the oceanic which is a metaphor
that um
that you offered us is proving to be
really stimulating for the crowd
and we just subtracted lars video in
hopes that it'll
strengthen his bandwidth here um but
but will lock it who's been the melon
postdoc helping us
you know conjured this entire symposium
will wonders about how
kaia silverman you know media theorist
sees the oceanic as a kind of um useful
analogy uh that also brings us
into an affinity
uh with the past that might be
problematic but will wants to take this
in a more generous
kind of hospitality direction that
you're now suggesting
is is our ai more analog now
in its kind of receptivity to human
impulses and intuitions
and can we render it thereby
more susceptible to some of our troubled
pasts and some of our troubled
relationships to our past can we make it
more permeable
uh to its own biases that we've baked
into it might be another way of putting
it
and lars we can't see you but if you
have something to say just blurt it out
wow we're hearing little bits
of you
hello hello no i'm not coming through
we heard hello hello
and yeah you still hearing you're still
picking up
yes we've got our ocean the oceans
between us
are proving extremely non-communicable
communicable
but maybe jana you want to pick up
will's question about whether
whether you experience ai i mean you've
had quite a bit of artistic
engagement with machine learning and
with the computational
as metaphor and as technology
would you would you say that you're
finding a little bit more permeability
now
to this interface that might make it
more open
to some of our own troubles and
differences
um certainly i think we should
should thrive to our strive to that end
and and i'm uh hopeful in terms of
uh art uh giving some space to
these sorts of experiments and and the
possibility to
to feed in uh critical also useless
content
uh to the these intelligent machines
um and i've certainly
been surprised by machine learning
algorithms
in the the recent years uh this this
this black box that that we've been
talking about i i feel
if even though i knew what i fed into
the machines it's always been
the results have often been eerie
strange
something that i didn't expect i've
often i've also been in this kind of
poetic
troubles of having to dumb down the
algorithms because otherwise they would
become
too boring because they're too uh too
smart
so to say or or they see
world to to clearly too much like us um
things like this but but uh but but i'm
on my own behalf at least i'm trying to
use my my position and and the
possibility to use some of these
machine learning algorithms towards
making some sort of useless strange
cuts in there or or inserts
you should say probably yeah
well i love in your work how each
project wants
to be applied in multiple forms with
phone interfaces and you know a video
and possibly you know something more
immersive
so maybe you and lars
might have some thoughts about the you
know post
covid the kind of the spatial
interface with the kind of vibrational
ai that you're now exploring the
vibrational machine
learning that you're now exploring in
wet on wet
do you you imagine a real-time interface
of that
with with a person in their kitchen with
some water and an iphone
hopefully not directly in the iphone but
you know
some kind of mediated uh interface
is that something you'd want to just
forecast for us about how you see that
work
going forward and whether ai gives you
permission to do some of these uh
stranger things with these molecules
that marcus
wants us to believe in
[Laughter]
uh certainly hope so and and um
and as as far as the the multiple media
of the work and and especially at a time
like this when
when a lot of work thoughts uh
emotions somehow need to be channeled
through
online interfaces uh via via machines
and
and and so on i try to find ways to
to use for example sound is a pretty
good
medium in that that those terms that it
travels
travels uh well uh through wires and
and and still can create a very
rich experience um
a very emotionally and and embodied
experience
in the the receiver and and i've been
thinking about
all these uh home rituals like for
example the
the sort of programming the esoteric
programming of water
with this uh vibrations or or
molecular frequencies that we've been
working on with marcus
oh i hear your larynx
sorry i didn't mean to interrupt you no
come on
we've got about we've got about five
minutes left in the discussion
and if we can hear you lars i'd love to
have your thoughts a lot of the
commentary is coming in muhammad abboud
wonders about you know the machinery of
code structuring whether you ever get
into the
black box you know uh
with regard to randomness or not
randomness whether that's
a level of attention that you have and
then just to get
some of the last questions in the room
the virtual room
jennifer leung wants to think further
about the whiteness of ai
you know um there's a lot of
thoughts about medicalized exclusions in
the u.s as
covid rolls out so very very differently
in our you know highly disparate society
in any case the traditions of other
cultures is something she responds to in
your work with the
you know the yellow soup from china um
so anyway those are two very different
questions how inside the black box do
you
as an artist want to get and maybe lars
if we can hear you
you'll tackle this other question about
whether our machinic algorithms can
expand
to include these these other traditions
in these
other epistemologies
which bridges to the afternoon session
as well
can we hear you can you hear me
am i going through can you hear me all
right well
i think i just
to start with the black thing i think
it's significant that
andrew pickering also speculative
basics and of the unknowable
uh because things are pickering relative
cybernetics is always
getting on in an environment and
since uh cybernetic the the
communication and uh
that's privileged by is the feedback
loop
then feedback loop you are always
producing data
uh and they do so constantly and not
know you can never know
final outcomes so these are pro that are
running
index as we know and
in the in the world view of speculative
cybernetics
everything is networks um
the the isn't that the human brain is
the network it's
got a and from and from
recent science so i
i think that this idea of cyber as the
quality of the unknowable and the great
winter that lies in that um
isn't uh is is an important
image of figure to uh uh
to contrast the idea of the black box
it's a way making the blacks um
that's i guess to what talking about
when she talks about
what was it just said use things that
you
uh produ your work which is a
is a very humble way of putting
and then there's the network and the two
different
kinds of two different of the unknowable
thank you for that i think we got the
gist so andrew pickering the
epistemology of the unknowable
great places to end uh we're just going
to pull out to the big picture on the
symposium as a whole
and direct our fellow participants and
audience members to come
to the department
and and and say anything about
um you know your your
breakout session tomorrow and who else
will be there i think i think you'll be
with marcus maybe
in that session yes so we're gonna
speak about the wet on web project uh in
particular with
marcus so more about that tomorrow and
hopefully
some of the audience today can join join
that
discussion as well and hopefully the
connection will be
a bit better um
[Music]
yeah well i think we can i think we can
all embrace the very glitchy aesthetics
that came
out of our encounter because really our
open systems
included a lot of randomness and a lot
of noise which is in the spirit
of our so sure
that celebration um i'll hope that maybe
you guys can
uh come to the afternoon session with
jason edward lewis
and megan frederickson where we're going
to be talking about how megan as a
biologist uses
ai to to parse genomic relations and how
jason
sees the possibility of kinship with
machines
thank you
you